Aww yeah! You asked for it, and you got it!
Today we are bringing you another Harry Potter lesson,
and this time we'll be learning with the Potion Master at Hogwarts, Professor Severus Snape.
In fantasy stories, potions are liquids that
are put inside of bottles such as this one
and that have magical effects for the person who drinks it.
So, this is how you'll learn with today's lesson:
First, you will watch some clips with subtitles,
then we'll teach you all the most
important vocabulary pronunciation and
cultural context,
before you test everything you learn by watching
it a final time without subtitles
and answering some quiz questions.
Plus, we have this FREE PDF and MP3 lesson that
you can download to take your learning
to the next level.
I'll tell you more about that later.
For now, let's watch Harry in his first class with Professor Snape.
Hey do you enjoy making learning English a fun part of your everyday life?
Well, that's what we're all about helping you to do.
And with our Fluent with Friend course,
you will gain English fluency
by immersing yourself in the
first two seasons of Friends.
For 48 weeks
with 20+ page PDF Power Lessons,
vocabulary memorization software,
access to our Global Fluency Circle community
and so much more.
You can try it for FREE with our 3-part Masterclass,
which you will get when you download the
PDF and MP3 for this lesson.
Just click up at the top or down in the description
below to get your freebies for this lesson
with Harry Potter and
Join the Masterclass now!
So, every single week we help learners
like you understand fast-speaking natives
without getting lost,
without missing the jokes,
and without subtitles.
Just like Cafer, who says that our channel keeps them motivated to continue learning English.
And we're excited to join you
on your journey to fluency too!
All you have to do is hit that Subscribe
button, and the bell down below,
so you don't miss any of our new lessons.
All right! I hope you had a lot of fun today learning English with Snape and Harry Potter!
And don't stop the learning yet!
Be sure to check out one of our other videos
that I know you'll enjoy,
or that 3-part Masterclass that I told you about.
Now, it's time to go beyond the classroom,
and LIVE your English.
Aww yeah!